[Laughter]
[Music]
this round little unicellular creature
came to us via a plankton net a mesh
with tiny microscopic holes through
which we ran hundreds and hundreds of
liters of water letting us collect
anything too large to pass through we
haven't been able to identify this
species yet making it a bit of a mystery
but the bigger mystery is still to come
because this little creature is about to
undergo that most universal and
unknowable experience of all death death
comes to the micro cosmos in many forms
like this denter polymorphous slowly
expelling the contents of its once
trumpet-like body into the surrounding
environment or this dead larva whose
exoskeleton is now an inanimate host to
two unicellular organisms even the
mighty tardigrade which has survived as
a species through multiple mass
extinctions is not immune to death
[Music]
this is of course the natural order of
things
predators hunt and their prey attempt to
survive with varying levels of success
this is lakhs of filum meleagris a large
unicellular organism that we've shown
before eating a rotifer this one is
practically stuffed with those
multicellular creatures we counted five
rotifers inside of it but sometimes the
predator becomes the prey and even the
locks of fill Emilia Greece has to find
ways to ensure survival when other
species come after it this seemingly
unlikely threat is the lack romário
Oller its name in Latin means tears of a
swan a name that suits both its teardrop
shape and its neck like extension which
gets up to eight times longer than its
body in search of prey sometimes we can
see its neck poking out of the dirt on
our microscope slide but even knowing
that you'd be forgiven for thinking that
it's unlikely that something so small
could pose a problem for those larger
lakhs of Philip and yet the lack romário
manages to take quite a chunk out of the
locks of filum the locks of film though
survives thanks to its ability to
regenerate
the piece that was taken but not all
prey get so lucky here this rotifer has
been killed by a Helios Owen destined to
become food a fate that this flagella is
about to share as it becomes captured by
a Helios Owen that is in the middle of
cell division the flagella has been
trapped by those long extensions called
EXO pods that radiate out from the
Helios Owens body as the flagella comes
further in it will be engulfed by the
cells into its own food
apartment called a vacuole there it will
be lysed open and its contents digested
by the Helios OA in the end though the
natural order comes for predators to
hear another Helios Owens dying cellular
body attracts the various decomposers of
the microbial world aside from predators
there are many other factors that lead a
single-celled organism to die changes in
temperature oxygen concentration pH
water quality so much more this
single-celled organism is swollen
because the water surrounding it is
entering the cell via osmosis many
organisms have water pumps called
contractile vacuoles that they use to
push water back out and prevent that
swelling but as in the case of this
organism sometimes those contractile
vacuoles stopped working and when that
happens the cell swells and explodes
other times the cause of death is harder
to determine like this para de Leptis
that spent several hours swimming before
going still its shape beginning to
change until it melts away seeming to
kill not only the para de Leptis but
this small green cells swimming nearby
but leaving other smaller flageolets
seemingly unaffected
and this brings us back to the beginning
with our mystery organism that is about
to undergo a death laden with even more
mysteries at first the cell looks like
it's just melting away dissolving into
something that resembles a microbial
Milky Way except that for a few seconds
it almost looks like the cell membrane
is able to close itself back up we think
though we can't know for sure that some
of the mechanisms inside this cell are
still working and that the organism is
trying to recover but alas survival is
not in the cards its membrane goes
through lysis releasing its insides to
the surrounding environment this death
is unlike any other kind of death we
have observed under our microscope and
we're still not sure what caused it
perhaps there were so many organisms in
this sample that they depleted the
oxygen and this organism couldn't
continue cellular respiration but
perhaps it was something else
death at every size holds its own
mysteries but it also reveals the
observations we make even the guesses we
come up with tell us about the way these
microbes interact with their environment
the way their bodies work and the
connections that exist between them it
is only ever in the mysteries that
knowledge is waiting to be found
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us if you want to see
more from our master of microscopes
James check out Jam and germs on
Instagram where he is constantly posting
cool stuff and if you want to see more
from journey to the micro cosmos here on
YouTube there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]